I
can't breakdance.
My name is Thomas Perrin pug,
I am 34 years old
and I am committed to the European elections.
I have been a researcher for 10 years,
It's been 10 years
that I work with men and women
politicians from all political sides,
and I have seen those who are interested,
I also saw what we don't give a shit about.
And as a result,
I ended my research career
to be able to
become a candidate for the European elections
and power uh.
Join the ranks of the uh.
0 MPs who fight naturally on a daily basis.
For me,
the fight of my life,
is to make Europe an ecological power
and social.
Climate change is here,
even at home, in Normandy,
my camp town,
it was uh. Flooded
and at other times Normandy is dry.
And if there is the strike in Normandy,
I let you imagine what is happening elsewhere.
The fight of my life,
is that we can in 1 word,
uh,
build 1 lifestyle that is better,
who is better for us,
human beings,
but which is also uh.
More respectful of the planetary limit,
more respectful of this environment of which we,
human beings,
let us be an integral part.
Yeah,
so me,
my secret boot,
is that I've actually been uh.
I've been in the military,
I was a reserve officer,
uh
of the army,
and therefore,
I kept my bosses' band with me,
I learned brotherhood,
the surpassing of myself
and also the overcoming of a collective,
because when we are together,
that we show cohesion
and that we are able to move mountains.
On nine/06,
we vote in the European elections,
we vote for the list carried by Rafael Guzman,
we are changing Europe,
we make Europe this power
ecological and social
of which we all,
all need.